[Music]
more than once over the past several
months i have predicted that we would
see a reported skyrocket
we would see a skyrocketing rise of
adhd diagnoses as millions of children
are forced to sit and stare at screens
all day in lieu of receiving a real
education that's what i
predicted i think i said it on the show
multiple times i tweeted it
uh now usually i enjoy saying i told you
so i don't hate saying i told you so i
love saying it
this is not one of the times where i
enjoy saying it uh this is one of the
times where i really do hate saying it
but
but i told you so this week um
nbc news reported right on schedule that
adhd diagnoses have
skyrocketed during the pandemic the
article by olivia solin
offers more details starting with an
anecdote this is what she this is what
she reports
it says susan mclaughlin's 12 year old
daughter isabella was a straight a
student before the pandemic isabella who
lives in a suburb the suburb of
a suburb of columbus ohio excelled at
science and math and was already getting
high school credit for algebra
but when her school shut down in march
and classes shifted to zoom isabella
great isabella's grades took a nosedive
she signed on for her virtual class from
a desk piled high with books papers and
stuffed animals and then spent hours
trying to clean her room
instead of focusing on schoolwork she
found herself paralyzed by assignments
mclaughlin said
but she wouldn't tell her teacher over
email that she was struggling as she
would have done in person
mclaughlin 53 a mother of three from
delaware ohio says it was a meltdown
after meltdown after meltdown
mclaughlin spent months trying to bring
more structure to isabella's day by
writing lists schedules timelines
checkboxes
but as someone as someone who was
diagnosed with attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder herself a decade
ago
mclaughlin realized that she was seeing
the same behaviors in isabella
she thought quote i've got to nip this
in the bud
isabel is being evaluated by a
psychiatrist
a process that takes several hours and
requires her teachers to fill out
questionnaires about her behavior
mclaughlin hopes that with an adhd
diagnosis isabella will be able to get a
prescription for a stimulant medication
such as ritalin adderall
uh or something like that to alleviate
her symptoms okay
pausing here for a second strange
strange isn't it the child was a
straight a student
everything was fine then she was
confined to a house for a year
put in front of a screen and suddenly
she has trouble learning
she must have a mental disorder yes that
must be it no other explanation comes to
mind
more from nbc news it says two dozen
parents pediatricians psychiatrists
psychologists and researchers all
described a crisis among children
suffering from inattention
and tanking school performance
data from specialists involved with
diagnosis diagnosing and treating adhd
show
just how much parents are struggling to
get help they're flooding an adhd
support line with questions and adhd
diagnoses and prescriptions for related
medications have soared
the number of parents calling a helpline
set up for um set up by
children and adults with attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder that's an
organization a non-profit
that supports people with adhd rose by
62
since the pandemic started traffic to
its website last year grew by 77
compared to 2019. aetna health a
technology company that creates
uh creates practice management software
for healthcare providers
published research in may drawing on
data from its customers that showed an
increase in patients age 13 to 17 who
received new diagnosis
diagnosis of adhd from the week of march
9th to the week of march 30th
the proportion of visits by teenagers
that involve first-time adhd diagnosis
rose by 67 percent
that was a similar spike among teenagers
especially boys
okay it should be i hope
clear to most people that it's not a
coincidence to find so many children
having trouble with inattention and
hyperactivity when they're cooped up
deprived of their normal outlets like
sports and other physical activities
and forced to learn through zoom classes
you know
i suffer quite a bit from inattention
when i
am forced to sit through even a
15-minute zoom meeting
i can't imagine doing it every day for
hours and being 12 years old on top of
it
the trouble here is with is with the
final d in adhd that's where i've got an
issue
or really both d's deficit and disorder
okay it's not only wrong
but arrogant and cruel to call a child
disordered
because he's struggling to learn in an
environment like that
the deficit the disorder is with the
environment
not the child it is disordered
to lock kids inside to try to teach them
through a screen
that's disordered kids who struggle
with that are healthy it's natural it's
healthy
to struggle under those circumstances
your kids
should struggle actually
yes it may help um it may help them sit
still to put them on drugs and
tranquilize them but if you're gonna do
that
and i don't think you should but if you
do it
don't pretend you're treating an illness
or disorder don't don't don't
fool yourself you know you need your kid
to sit still
and look at zoom for six hours and so
you put them on drugs
all right i really wish you wouldn't i
think it's terrible to do it
but if you do at least be honest and do
not claim that you're treating a
disorder
because you know you're not you know
that's not what you're doing
you're trying to get your kid a
competitive advantage in this certain
environment or context
okay like a guy who isn't good at
baseball
is not disordered um
not thriving in baseball is not a sign
of a disorder so if he takes steroids
he's not treating an illness he can't
say that he suffers from
a baseball deficiency no he's just
he wants to succeed in this specific
specialized environment known as
baseball
and so he's taking the drug to help him
do that
it's the same thing here a child who
doesn't thrive while staring at a screen
for five hours
is also not disordered that is not a
symptom of a disease
so putting them on drugs it's like
doping it's it's it's just to give them
that advantage
who is to say that children should
thrive in that environment
we've decided that we want them to
but that doesn't mean they should giving
him a drug to help
is not a medical decision then even if a
doctor prescribes it
you're also not doing it to help him
exactly the kids are being drugged while
they're stuck at home
in order to make things easier on the
teachers and on the parents and on this
system generally
that's who this is for now i think this
is probably clear to most people as it
relates to the spike in adhd during the
pandemic i think most people can
put two and two together here right
here's the part where i might lose you
if you've been with me so far maybe it
turned on me here i don't know
this same logic applies outside of the
pandemic
adhd diagnoses have been increasing for
decades we're seeing
what we're seeing during the lockdowns
is just a dramatic microcosm of our
general societal
situation before the pandemic and
presumably once this is over whenever
that is
we're going to go back um to to you know
where kids are expected to sit in a
classroom with 30 other kids for six or
seven hours a day listening to lectures
filling out worksheets
taking tests based mostly on
memorization
now i think that's better than them
staring at a screen for six hours
but it's still not good at least not for
a lot of kids
kids who don't thrive in that specific
environment kids who struggle to learn
in that environment
kids who struggle to pay attention are
diagnosed as distort disordered and put
on drugs
but just as a child's failure to thrive
on
zoom shouldn't be considered a symptom
of illness
a child's failure to thrive in public
schools should also
not be considered a symptom of illness
see
the adhd diagnosis is situational
it is diagnosed largely based on how the
child's disorder
quote unquote interferes with school and
home life
other illnesses aren't diagnosed this
way if you take your child to the doctor
because you think he has diabetes
the doctor is not going to ask you um is
his diabetes interfering with school and
home life
no that'd be a non-sequitur who cares
what it's interfering with he's got
diabetes
let's get him treated but adhd is only
adhd
if it causes problems in these
environments that's those are the
symptoms that's how they determine it
the the mayo the mayo clinics fact sheet
on adhd says this this is what they say
okay reading now from the mayo clinic
is what they say baby about adhd they
say a child who shows a pattern of
inattention may often
fail to pay to pay close attention to
details or make careless mistakes in
school work
have trouble staying focused in tasks or
play appear not to listen even when
spoken to directly
have difficulty following through on
instructions and fail to finish school
work or chores
have trouble organizing tasks and
activities avoid or dislike tasks that
require focused mental effort such as
homework
lose items based lose items needed for
tasks or activities for example toys
school assignments pencils be easily
distracted
and finally forget to do some daily
activities such as forgetting to do
chores
okay yeah that's how you know that
there's
adhd not only does this all sound
exactly like
every child i've ever met
but it also revolves suspiciously around
schoolwork
what i'm arguing is that our underlying
assumption here is wrong
we're assuming so this is really a
philosophical thing
okay um the the adhd discussion is a
philosophical discussion more than
anything else
so you could i know i'm going to get the
emails and everything saying oh you're
not a doctor how could you be saying
this
what i'm saying is that the doctors who
are diagnosing this stuff
they are going outside of what their
realm should be
they're going way above and beyond
they're going way above their own pay
grade
and i'll tell you why
because to diagnose adhd
it is to assume that every child
should be able to sit still and pay
attention in a public school environment
i'm suggesting that some children many
children can't
and that's not because there's something
wrong with them
it's because there's something wrong
with us and with the system
and with the mold that we're trying to
put them in
so i believe that children who exhibit
adhd behaviors
exist obviously sure my sons do
and they exist i do and i exist last i
checked
what i don't believe is that those
behaviors are disordered
see that that's again my issue is with
the d here
disordered in order to call something
disordered you must first have an idea
of what the proper order is
so what's the proper order for a child
how is a child
supposed to be how is he supposed to act
how is he supposed to think
you say an adhd child thinks the wrong
way well what's the right way
who decided that
an adhd child has a lot of trouble
focusing on schoolwork
okay who's to say he's supposed to be
able to do that
who's to say that he should be able to
do that
what do we wh someone maybe if you could
show me
what is the model brain that we're
basing all this on
if you're saying that a child has a
deficiency of attention
well how much attention is he supposed
to have
show me the child who all the other kids
are supposed to be like
what are we judging this against
and who decided that so don't tell me oh
the doctors decided who gave them that
authority
yeah a doctor can look and and
physically diagnose things but who gives
them the authority to decide
how a child is supposed to think and how
he's supposed to learn
and why have we seeded that that those
kinds of judgments over to
medicine that's philosophical is what
that is
there's a lot of other things too but
it's also philosophical
i suggest again that the real disorder
is with the system
i would argue that if there's an
education system
that cannot function unless millions of
the kids in its care are drugged
then the education system is fatally
flawed
that to me is a symptom of the education
system
being disordered so i'm going to be the
doctor now looking at the education
system and diagnosing it
and when i look and see that
you you can't function this doesn't work
unless millions of kids are on
psychotropic medication
yeah that tells me there's something
wrong here there's something very wrong
and it's not with our kids
it's with the system
and what they're doing now during the
the lockdown is just evidence of that
they're locking these kids down making
them go to school on a computer
and if it doesn't work they put them on
drugs it is
infuriating and disgusting and we should
all be
uh furious about it
so who's canceled um did
everybody everybody involved that's that
it's this is a very general one
adhd maybe that's what's canceled here
listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated